Welcome to AERA English's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Now, today's Maestro Hook.
The Maestro Hook is a conversation piece you can use with a foreigner when you run out of topics.
Today's Maestro Hook is about heroes in a movie in the States.
Now remember, when a hero is in a very devastating situation,...
...in a foreign movie, they always make a joke.
They act really funny.
Why is that?
In Japanese movies, they never do that because it's a very serious scene.
But in foreign movies, the superheroes want to show that they are very confident and they are not worried.
So, for example, he's in a tight situation, he says,...
..."Ha! I wonder what I'm gonna have for lunch today." Like that.
So, this is Western culture.
All superheroes do that. So please, when you watch a movie, check it out.
Now,...
Not in my dictionary.
Just who do you think I am?
Okay. So, Maestro Lines.
Oh! We're never gonna finish that report in time.
Not in my dictionary!
I can't believe you finished the report in time.
Ha! Just who do you think I am?
Okay, I think they're here.
So, that's it for today's news and I'll see you guys later on Maestro Menu.
Bye-bye!